yeah okay it's tea we carry feet
slipping into feet I know patience is
the key putting out all of my [ __ ] for
free this is T we carry v michael makeup
yo good morning we're back we are back
after a little hiatus I missed you I'm
sorry
hope everybody super well it's coming in
the tea is here and we are on with tea
with Gary be super excited on this
Tuesday morning
and let's get right into it I does
summer ones and twos and today's a huge
day we have a monster thing coming out
I'll be probably looking at my phone a
little bit here during the during the
show because something's about to launch
on the internet that's gonna make your
head explode and I am working on it
feverishly and so I'm a little
distracted a little bit more to normal
please bear with me because there's
breaking news but I didn't want to
cancel today's show because we've been
on for Friday and Monday and so on to
get back so let's get right into it
Dustin let's get right into it how are
you so listen one of the things that
we've done in our company is we put
together I'm gonna give you a little
context for answer one question we put
together a model of coronavirus buying
decision making amongst 150 to 200
million consumers and we put it together
this data over the last few days to see
why people were making purchasing
decisions and one thing we found in the
last four weeks a complete skill a
complete jump from aiming we've seen the
last 10 years where people are buying
for three reasons only right now helping
others safety and Trust over the last
few years you've seen this as well
significance acquiring well showing I
break your those were a lot of the key
buying decisions purchasing decisions
that buyers are making and it's
completely flip-flop and so there are a
lot of business owners right now built
their business over the last few years
on trust safety and helping others they
haven't gotten traction and so I'm super
curious from you right what do you tell
business owners and it feels like this
is their moment
um offense if they can deliver it right
a lot of people built or you know
untrust or things that nature and don't
have the logistics or the infrastructure
to actually take advantage of it given
the nature of whatever they sell so you
know to me the answer during good times
and the answer during bad times
challenging times
opportunistic times is always offense
offense comes in the form of
communication communication comes in the
form of advertising or original content
or acting like a media company so you
know to me I'm seeing a lot of this
similar trend trans Vil and I I'm
watching people for example I have
friends who are like my econ business is
up to X because they have a trust
oriented soap or something and I'm like
how is your behavior and they're like
what do you mean I'm like are you
spending then I carry we're converting
better than ever on Facebook and
Instagram because a lot of people have
pulled out their ads because their
businesses are bad and I'm like really
not why are you not 7 X in your spend if
you have the month like people are you
know you've got to know when to strike
you know I've only had one real obvious
moment in my career where all my savings
came I had all my savings
I didn't eat a lot of money building my
dad's business for him but I didn't
spend any money I lived in a shitty
apartment and just saved and I had this
moment where I just believed in social
media and I saw Facebook Twitter Tumblr
and I spent all my money on investing in
those companies and I remember at the
time was like should I have held back
20% of my savings things that nature but
it was black and white to me yeah and if
I'd held back those 20% that would have
been millions and millions and millions
of dollars lost and so it's funny when
you were telling that story that's what
I went back to that moment if you've got
a business that was built on that if
you're seeing the traction you're not
just watching this video and you're like
okay let me spend all my money they're
seeing the indications of traction
because you have the ability to execute
you have to go all-in yeah and so I
really like to community which is the
platforms that people are going to right
now on digital it's Facebook Instagram
and YouTube and Frank and weird
enough access not because that's what
news is Twitter it's actually a pretty
decent platform to advertise on me now
but here's the crazy thing
25 percent of all Americans right now
making purchasing decisions or watching
local news and consuming local you know
newspapers local whatever that is equal
to what everybody is watching on the
cable news networks right now so 25
percent of America are watching the
cable news networks and 25 percent of
America is just focused on traditional
local news and I know you always talk
about this about how there are
efficiencies sometimes in local TV local
and traditional advertising it feels
like this is one of those moments
the debate there is so I understand that
like even for me I have local 2 4 & 7 on
quite a bit because there's a little bit
of a warmth of a face that you've known
for 34 years like delivering it to me
the question is the commercials how you
know are you know what's happening to
reversal time because we're seeing a lot
of interesting things during bigger TV
events right now where the social like
we've been watching last month and the
social spike during commercial times you
know as soon as a president's briefing
or a breaking news or about you speaking
or you know or Cuomo's on like we're
seeing a ton of massive spikes I think
we now live in a world of consuming the
main thing and then immediately going
here and giving our two cents which
inevitably means the commercials having
a harder time penetrating us and so yes
there's definitely there's always
efficiencies it's a real we're seeing a
lot of similar things my question is I'm
always trying to get people to separate
the content from the commercial right so
Phil it's great to see you man take care
let's keep it going a lot of interesting
stuff going on out there and whoa what's
up what's a hearing so before I ask my
question I was on plan of the apps so it
was me and my two business partners and
we were I wasn't on the show because
they only wanted two people but I was
evolved
tracking out with your voice Oh get out
of here yeah so that was my members
yelled at them for playing
rock-paper-scissors live that was me and
I was super bummed that we didn't get
you but um yeah because I didn't get to
me because they're really strict but you
know patience finally meets you three
years later um so my question is this my
last company the one that was on plan of
the apps ultimately ended up not working
it was my first startup I'm a software
engineer we raised two million dollars
made a bunch of marketing mistakes so
now I'm actually working on a new
project that I'm really passionate about
and it's a travel subscription app I was
supposed to launch last month so now my
question for you is when would you
launch number one it's and number two I
want to spend the marketing dollars
right this time I've like a smaller
budget twenty to fifty K how would you
market a travel subscription app and I'm
thinking it's geared towards Millennials
mostly but that's kind of where I'm
standing it cost 99 bucks a month so I
would probably I would spend the
marketing on Facebook and I would target
upper millennial you know high net worth
individuals cuz $99 a month
subscriptions a real number and I need
people to actually have money
twelve hundred bucks a year so I would
go very high end Facebook I would I
would launch it minimum Li a hundred
days after things went back to normal
whether that's three months six but you
have you need a hundred days of data
like I'm very concerned people are
scared yeah humans by nature are very
very capable of being fear-based I mean
on a good day I can't see travel if
everything goes well travel should be
down 20 percent right because there's a
bunch of people like I'm not traveling
the Coronas gonna come back yeah I know
yeah so that's what I was thinking too
so assuming things go back to normal in
May or June you would think minimum at
least three months minimum because
because main June
I won the way I think about it September
becomes normal because May June July
August is like staggered right I mean I
think I think you need to be mentally
prepared that you might have to wait -
you might have to wait here a little bit
that's what I mean maybe maybe I don't
know I feel like maybe November 1st
maybe maybe January 15th in that range
ok my guess if I was the partner right
now be like hey let's mentally prepare
for that range ok cool and then I face
book Facebook Ads
targeting towards people that travel and
then I would what I also do is give away
a tenth of a point up to three points of
the company so 30 big time 2 3 4 million
followers on Instagram travel people
uh-huh and I'd give them a tenth of a
point of the company in advisory shares
mm-hmm in exchange for a you know real
promotion around the app right awesome
thank you so much that's a really
important point I want to make sure you
grasp that one by giving up three points
of your company which is 3% of 0 first
with such a small budget it can really
be the match that gets your business
going and there are some significantly
large travel influencers on Instagram
that are going to be definitely worth a
tenth the point and they've never owned
a piece of a company further right so
they're gonna over deliver for what
you're giving them in return I think
it's a big an important part of your
strategy awesome thank you someone's
here take care Lori Lori J on Facebook
what's good highly be what's good John
Rawlings what's good good to see
everybody this morning Brendan done
Eugene let's keep it going dust good to
see you Megan Josh it's good yeah how
you doing Gary well how can I help you
so basically you know it's pretty simple
so basically I grew up in a family that
all I ever knew was now and basically my
family was always just this is just
enough so basically I liked overachieve
and I basically have two jobs now and
anytime I talk to anybody my family tell
me I'm doing too much I don't know what
to do now
basically I'm stuck you know I have two
jobs sometimes three depend on what I'm
doing that week and I work I'm essential
working I work for ovaries and I work
for gold buff and just what do you mean
you don't know what to do you like
believe them that you're doing too much
no I don't you know I'm the only one the
over cheese
besides all them you know I make enough
money I'm I'm satisfied why I am now but
I want to know what I could do next
like I feel stuff you know well what
what do you a mean for well I eventually
do want to start a like a youtube
channel basically um I feel like I have
enough content around what I do in order
to make YouTube but every time like for
example at the beginning of this year I
just got my car back then I was homeless
for a little bit so we just got back
into a new house back on the being of
this month so basically I'm building
slowly but every time I get towards my
goal something else pops up you know um
well let's let's take a step back what
um what makes you happy what makes me
happy well I'll be honest my son makes
me very happy
that's awesome man yeah my son he's very
happy on you know the stuff that he is
about to be seven in May it's amazing
okay so so basically you know basically
everything we do me and my girlfriend
everything we do is based off of him you
know we live for and basically and you
know like basically for example we
promised him a Playstation and still to
this day was still trying to get that
because something else always comes up
and we're always trying to battle that
we're gonna do we're gonna do two things
one you're gonna email me and I'm gonna
send you a PlayStation for him okay
that's gonna happen right now
soon hang up email me at Gary at
vaynermedia and I'll get you a
Playstation 2 - you're gonna try not to
make things with him let me rephrase you
get the parent the way you want a parent
one I'm gonna get you the PlayStation so
good the little man's got a PlayStation
2 my recommendation one man's point of
view you know how to parent you do your
thing
I don't think gold should be around
stuff okay because you're training him
to put things on a pedestal right you
know I talk a lot about keeping up with
the Joneses like you know I'm always
scared that people want to BMW I I think
it starts early I think when you make
stuff like the North Star and it makes
sense to me when I hear homeless
struggle you know when I hear all that
right I'm hearing you you're the only
one overachieving and you've got you're
going through the grind some like [ __ ]
me and this guy came from the dirt you
know what I mean
yeah I've got a lot of respect for you
and and I know that when when people
come from that place stuff is on a
pedestal you know when you got nothing
and TV and then the internet is showing
you stuff you want that but I also think
that leads to enormous amounts of
unhappiness no you're a hundred percent
right you know III you're hundreds in
rate all over one it was amazed his cars
and showing off their everybody else but
eventually I started to overgrow that
once I became homeless for a little bit
with my girlfriend my son I agree that
very quickly and I realized I mean
humility doesn't get you anywhere I want
to make sure your son doesn't get caught
he was seven six when he felt
homelessness he's now gonna put
PlayStation on a pedestal that's okay
don't like he's gonna have that
happiness that's good but I think I
think it's he's super early by the way
you're super early to flip the script on
[ __ ] stuff that may also be the unlock
to you feeling stuck if you go for
happiness for the process then then all
of a sudden like it's crazy I know
people don't believe me when I'm like I
don't care about all that I love my game
so much I don't care about all the stuff
they're like yeah yeah yeah you're about
that money you're you're happy you got
that like they don't understand they
really don't I'm telling you the truth
my man
they don't understand when you just love
that what you're doing and you love the
people around you when you're doing it
you've won and so I think you I want to
make sure you're not stuck because
you're trying to figure out how to
maintain a roof over your head and then
start something that may make enough
money to go at it based on the car the
PlayStation stuff I don't want you to do
that I want you to take a
back and really think about like what
you like doing and and how do you just
like not give a [ __ ] about stuff I'm
telling you right now man if you can
really like when you were homeless you
didn't give a [ __ ] about that stuff
because you know you were at that place
where you're like [ __ ] I need a roof
right you're right but now that you've
got the roof
you know what starts trickling in you're
like let me put some stuff in this roof
mm-hmm I don't want you to like that
you're still early enough and I
definitely want you to fight for the kid
like you know basically you know we
literally still sleep on the air
mattress you know straight from the
grind straight from the me we are doing
it from the bottom to the top trying to
make everything possible you know I'm
outside working every day six to eight
hours and sometimes even more if we need
to you know so yeah I'll be honest with
you 16 hours not a lot of time of work I
mean that with my career and love I know
I'm right and but I but I think that
you're coming from such a place right
that like I'm listening right
overachieving
this is where I'm at six to eight hours
I'm like man again I'm like okay this
guy really really got raised in an
environment that demonized work or
demonized success or like played it safe
or were fearful or many other things
that I don't know we're just trying to
get on here but but let me tell you
something
like when you're on air mattress and
water line you know I'm on in and out of
like being homeless I promise you and
this is from the love place of I think
you got a good sense of me this coming
from straight love Josh six to eight
hours ain't [ __ ] I became the got got so
basically so basically I was raised my
own grandparents my mom said at three
months old I cried way too much
she handed me right off so my
grandparents basically raised me and
both of them since the age about 45
lived off Social Security and SSI they
never wanted to overachieve or risk that
because they know what was beyond that
so basically they always shelter me in a
local [ __ ] it's rather like hide me away
from life you know so basically I
and the little childhood I'm trying so
much on arose childhood now because I
didn't have that I didn't get to go out
and have fun my friends cuz I wasn't
allowed to have friends and I wasn't
allowed to go outside and play off the
black because I could get hurt and I was
always safe and basically everybody else
that I'm around basing my cousins we all
grew up in the same age I'm the only one
that's doing something my life we're
trying to do something because everybody
else is just trying to just stay at zero
I got it I listen like the one of the
great things that ever happened to me
was I went to a really underperforming
academic college now I to college and it
was it was this world man
like I imagine me surrounded by people
who wanted to figure out how to trick
the government to like let them not work
or coming from really adverse you know I
came from some adverse [ __ ] but like
like very quickly there was stability
and then prosperity started to grow you
know like people are coming from grinds
dirt and like I was in that world for
four years and that was my friend base
and that was my Society that was my
culture and it you know besides being an
empath it I was really in the frontlines
of it right and so I I don't judge you
right like I'm reading the comments and
everyone's like this [ __ ] six to
eight hours then even a full you know
and I understand where you're coming
from on the flip side I really
understand where you're coming from I
think you need to hear you know more
ambition I think you need to download 15
to 20 you know app podcasts and just
listen to ambition 24/7 24/7 ambition in
your ears
because what's happening is you're
comparing yourself to people that have
zero ambition and so you think you're
overachieving at six to eight hours and
then when we got through this talk we're
like whoa you're not even starting of
course and that's good there's nothing
wrong with that who gives a Josh step
number one this is for everybody out
there anybody who's in a predicament
step number one is [ __ ] yesterday it
doesn't matter
it doesn't matter if you work zero hours
six for your grandparents your mom you
know abandonment that's the worst you
like you can sit and dwell and explain
to me your girl your little guy you can
explain to the world why you didn't or
you can say I had this [ __ ] ten
minutes with Gary like like I'm deciding
to look a different way and I'm so
goddamn young which you are how old are
you 25 your baby you're right you know I
mean your baby but you need to put
twenty four-hours-a-day of ambition in
your ears don't let that become delusion
don't make it about the money make it
about the process of getting happy which
also has the chance of bringing you
value financially potentially but if you
go for happiness like there's so many
things that stood out from this call
with me one just the way you talked
about like this way you smiled when you
said your son I already knew we were
good but then also the delusion that you
think six to eight hours is going at it
I'm like okay this guy's really in that
cocoon we gotta pull him the [ __ ] out
Josh I'm trying to pull you the [ __ ] out
so basically I work I work 16 hours as a
hobby before I go into work seeing
that's the thing you know I mean that's
why I wanted to talk to you because
basically like I said I'm stuck you know
basically 60 hours I words to say two
hours because basically those are only
hard times to make good money basically
it's only good hard times to make money
on driving Reed's
yeah what you could do is shoes you're
done with the last [ __ ] delivery of
some [ __ ] pizza is go to Goodwill and
spend 18 bucks find some [ __ ] posted
that night and make 88 oh yeah and
that's another thing too I really like
the resale things like I'm really good
at not know you don't you like the
thought of it if you liked it the way I
like it you do it 24/7 I used to [ __ ]
work 13 hours a day my dad's liquor
store then come home and post on eBay
that's color like you like the idea of
it you don't like it because work ethic
isn't [ __ ] in your blood
yet anything could be taught you know
how many muscles I had zero [ __ ] six
years ago then I finally got it in
to my system and now I work out and that
like you can anybody I mean I thought I
could never be healthy in my workout
regimen I hate it I still hate it but I
got over the hoop where I made it
palpable enough cuz I know it matters
you need to [ __ ] learn to love work
all right sounds good I like where your
eyes just went you understand not I'm
gonna use work to get that money too cuz
you understand you gotta get out of it
no no you have to love it so you do it
every [ __ ] minute and then and then
you got back it back out and bounce with
the Sun and the girlfriend all that but
like you need to find something you love
call it like because you don't like the
flip life you like the idea of it you
right everybody loves entrepreneurship
not anymore
now that's hard I'm getting all sorts of
crazy emails Ivan you know in dm's i
look at their accounts they were flexing
entrepreneur life bottles at the [ __ ]
club like yo entrepreneur life now
they're crying to me because they don't
know what the [ __ ] to do they didn't
love it
they loved the [ __ ] picture for the
gram mm-hmm they loved the two am
[ __ ] party that they'll never forget
they forgot that shit's dissing history
now they're [ __ ] scared you know why
cuz all their [ __ ] self-esteem is
wrapped up in being a [ __ ]
entrepreneur and now they're gonna have
to work at [ __ ] chase bank cuz
they're [ __ ] direct-to-consumer
t-shirt business is [ __ ] that's true
because they spent [ __ ] 1,400 on a
bottle Grey Goose trying to get that
girl instead of putting it in a bank
that's what they did what you need to do
is realize yours is a little bit
different you just don't have that
relationship with work see I never
really had everything like I said me
basically come from nothing and just
trying to build I'm trying to find my
way around but I'll be honest you Gary
I've pretty much limited mostly anything
I could do due to my body tattoos um I
do get looked at differently good news
that is the [ __ ] [ __ ] excuse of
all time if you think in 2020 I'll tell
you if you think
74 bro you're right it does you know I
went to a job interview like two weeks
ago for example you like real bro that's
one job you're right
that's one job you don't need [ __ ]
clients don't hire vaynermedia cuz I
curse straight talk you mean big
companies don't hire us because I'm on
LinkedIn like I'm gonna [ __ ] you know
they're like [ __ ] that that's one you're
right bro I promise you you can get any
what do you live Philadelphia bro you
can get any job at any coffee shop or
[ __ ] cool [ __ ] bar in Philadelphia
because you look the part instead of the
reverse they want your neck tattoo you
write hot fashion brand want your tattoo
[ __ ] hip hop brand wants your tattoo
you go into some stodgy ass [ __ ]
company fine but that's you setting up
for the L so you can use the excuse of
the tattoo
don't [ __ ] you know me I'm not
getting tricked out here I got you you
understand yeah I'm glad it's 2020 I
judge people who wear [ __ ] suits at a
time more than somebody's got a [ __ ]
tat of a [ __ ] eye drop on her [ __ ]
face
it's 2020 bro I dig it imma getting 100
Gary I promise listen to me your little
man needs this from you you need to show
him I'm gonna send you that PlayStation
cuz I promise that I want him to be
[ __ ] happy as [ __ ] but then on the
flip side right behind you but like look
dad work don't tell him we'll tell him
years later he'll watch this video your
dad worked hard for this and if you want
[ __ ] you got a work so this Saturday
we're going when the [ __ ] Crone is
over
we're going garage saleing I'm giving
you two dollars you're gonna buy some
[ __ ] we're gonna come home and we're
gonna post on eBay you teach him work
ethic now you make it his culture you
flip it and that's what I'm trying to do
you know me and my girlfriend both
trying you know show home that basically
everything you get is from the muscle
then known as I don't know nothing don't
don't show them in theory make them live
it okay let me tell you something my
brother and I AJ our relationship is
built on
and garage saleing when he was 14 I was
like let's go it's time to pluck and
really go at it and we would I would
wake up at six in the morning drive to
New Jersey he would drive he was at
first I'd have to pick him up a couple
years later get his license we'd meet
halfway at the Wine Library and would be
six in the morning [ __ ] cold in our
eye and [ __ ] the Sun getting coffee
and driving an hour to a [ __ ] flea
market buying [ __ ] for three hours
coming back home
[ __ ] posting that [ __ ] he would ship
them out the next day work ethic is
taught your grandpa taught you not to
work you persevered because you had the
DNA you [ __ ] persevered you keep you
did the hardest part bro but now I need
to push you to that next place cuz now
you're half pregnant you're in the
middle you understand
yeah understand gay but show that man
make that man work
I got you beauty good thank you you're
welcome
OOP Dustin yes sir that one I think that
was like four days pent up I think it
was a little pent up you know sometimes
when you're pent up it's kind of reminds
me of what the thing I was working on
yeah how you said if you put your focus
on the 15 percent you like that 85% more
you kind of like that yeah you can use
some of this content yep awesome let's
keep it going
admins team Gary you please look for
that email it's uh Josh it's Gary at
vaynermedia comm just put send me the
PlayStation [ __ ] all right let's
keep it going yeah I told the same so
he's on top of it
great thank you that was good Laura hey
hey Gary how you doing I'm doing well
how are you alright now I want you to
give it to me that last call
Wow that uh really resonated with me I
was homeless and my work ethic it wasn't
it wasn't great the last three years
I've been in between jobs and I've
really kicked it up I'm on multiple
social networks
then I posted my first article last
night so you listed on homelessness
because I can relate and um I finally
got an Instagram I'm on facebook I'm on
YouTube I have a check it and I've been
hitting it hard
I've had people tell me you know why are
you working so hard cuz if I don't have
a job my job is to get a job and I what
you've been talking about going to UM
not going to school not giving it all I
went all the way I spent 12 years in
college and I'm scared shitless I am I
am [ __ ] scared and I got a son and I
made a lot of bad choices
and he's with his dad it was amazing
father and because of those choices I'm
aware of it now I got my own place but
I'm delving into my investments and it
sucks because I'm being told by the
directors the hiring managers you're
gonna take my job we can't afford you
but you're not gonna stick around
because you're gonna find something
better and I I've been a client a jewel
at Walmart and and I mean I'm ready to I
mean I've been hitting the podcast hard
I've been watching your [ __ ] I've been
watching I'm gonna career for a
farmworker daily and I'm working it
every single day and I want to start a
live feed but I don't know which one to
go with I haven't I have a strong
profile I have a roast I believe I have
a strong profile I've gotten some really
good suggestions and tweaks to alter it
I'm very proud of that it's awesome but
I own I own the [ __ ] that I've done I
own the mistakes that I've made I can
see it I appreciate it [ __ ] those who
don't don't appreciate it cuz I
appreciate for me and I feel more
energized now than I have in probably 10
years and I went all the way with career
that she I mean marathons Pentagon
military just professionalism education
but I feel like it's it's it's hard to
UM all that other childhood [ __ ] my pH
DS and Family Studies all that childhood
shit's coming back all that feelings of
negative self-worth negativity and what
am I Wow
my son I'm sure he's learning things
he's 10 he'll be 11 next week yes mom
may I help you
yes sir thank you he holds the door he
says mom excuse me
I mean I really don't want to talk right
now is it okay if we talk it's in such a
time I mean what ten-year-old boy says
mom that's sexist when he sees stuff
that's racist when he says stuff I mean
that he who says that Santa's got to be
a boy I mean he's doing [ __ ] that I'd
never my dissertation was on at home
dads and my ex-husband he works full
time but he's literally an at home debt
he takes care of my son thank God
because I was not in a place that I was
able to do that cuz I made some serious
choices negative choices and hi I own it
yeah listen Laura one thing I can tell
you for sure that I see and I hope
people see it in your face
I'm I'm I admire accountability so much
like you know you're talking right now
and the admiration is pouring out of me
because you know being accountable leads
to so much happiness you know once you
can actually own it so much more good
can happen because of it so like you're
the fact that you're at that place
because I promise just knowing people
you were not at the accountable place
maybe seven years ago maybe four years
ago right you're in that delusional spot
the fact I mean my mind's I've made my
mint I know so I don't want to hear it
that's their stuff yeah that's right I'm
going to do I think I think the big
thing now is just going on the offense
on you know you had the great fortune
that your ex-husband was able to instill
kind of a foundation for the little guy
and so now you go off that momentum you
got to make sure that you have no
resentment no regret and you just go on
pure offense from this point then
towards them on the offense towards I'm
worth enough but I'm starting to feel
that I'm still in a state of toxicity I
feel like it's it's swallowing me I know
it's hard to get a breath
I know to give I just I don't want to
get in that pity pot pour me pour me
another drink I won't do that you know
listen I just I think I the sky the
networking is
amazing look I know I know where my line
in the sand it you know I know for
myself where I feel comfortable talking
about things and when things go to
another level where you know you know I
think I've brought talents of human
behavior and then I think there's actual
professionals and things that nature so
I think it's a combo one thing I can
tell you that's very obvious to me is
the community and that will you beat me
to it I think you have to do a Facebook
live today and just talk and interact
you have to you have to do that because
I think the ability to feel part of a
community is a massive massive oxygen
play in these kind of scenarios you know
I think you really need to think about
that I'm an empath like you and I'm an
energizer and I don't just wait I used
to go to classes in college and they say
I'd get out of the first class and like
my colleagues would say Lord you have
the first paper written it's II think
they knew I just I just go on and do I
don't I'm not gonna wait for oh I'll do
it when I when I feel like it what what
was what can I help you with like what
can I help you with I'm so scared
question or of what which which outlet
to go by how do i how do i how do i
market myself what am i what what do i
can't see me that's what I said what are
you trying to sell like it's an
important thing like what and when I say
sell it doesn't mean you're monetizing
it could mean you're monetizing no it
could be a little be legacy it could be
building community I think you have to
you have to start with the finish line I
want to have a sense of connection that
I have made a difference in someone's
life I've great news
you've already accomplished that in this
talk in the last five minutes I'm
telling you the truth you just need to
now listen I do the same thing I three
people you have to you have to go in
with confidence not insecurity depending
on on this scenario meaning the
following I need you here just very loud
and clear I used to do you streams that
had 13 people in it six you can sense
the connection is one you can go on
Facebook live right now you can hang up
right now on Facebook live if you have
facebook out one person might showed up
it doesn't matter how much money I have
in the bank the big how big my car
- was what kind of car I had if I just
made a difference in somebody's lap well
but listen Laura you need I need to make
sure you're just we're not being in full
of [ __ ] mode you can do that right now
yeah like that's very cute and I'm very
happy to hear that but like I've good
news you know go on right now literally
hang up right now and go on like like
how do I do that I mean it's cold I love
it just tell me because I because I'm
not right like that's the fun part
it's not only real it's coming from such
a good place you know what's amazing
about Google being the answer to that
then when you decide to go on faced
Instagram live and you don't know it's
Google like I Google is my education I
was a terrible student like like almost
everything I've learned has been
starting with Google 2000 up into this
point it's empowering right like people
are looking for excuses or or are
insecure and think they can't but the
answer is Google right and Mike's my
excuses consistently been throughout my
life I crave external validation to
increase my self-worth I was good at
school that's the one thing I was good
at in order to get good I mean oh when I
tell you that that was the obvious part
of this whole job when you said when you
said 12 out 12 years of school I
understood enough of college I get it I
knew that that's what you were look at
me and they resume and they think
something and then they don't know
what's going on inside they don't know
how I feel inside they look at me and
they assume something I present myself
in a way when I'm when I'm at work it's
on it is one there's something else and
they think that I'm I'm like like I'm
standoffish can I can I tell you
something you know there's a couple
there's two things that I want you to do
one I want you to go on Instagram or
Facebook live immediately immediately
like within the next hour - you have to
do what we talked about in the last call
you have
do at all costs spend zero seconds on
dwelling about yesterday
yesterday's yesterday's value to most
people is their absolute devastating
framework yesterday's value destroys
people I'm grateful for my past because
it's made me who I am and I got it I got
you and once that I've made not once did
I have a negative reception and that's
not what it's about I freed myself of
the burden of the burden of holding on
to that regret because I don't want to
reveal that [ __ ] and that's the best on
that if they took them it's a release it
Laura
its fate no it's no it's no no no no it
feels real to you but it's fake
I don't understand I'll explain you know
what as it is yeah
remember those in high school I used to
papa free myself I step on the window
and look at the weird shows but
nonetheless we before going to school
the next day thought it was [ __ ] a
big deal like it was in our [ __ ] head
you know dudes had it that it stays with
you it's a virus thing virus stick with
me Laura you had it big in your own head
but in school when you got there in
reality people were worried about their
own zits you have a framework where
you're worried about other people's
opinions that resentment towards you
their judgement toward you you value
value it without realizing how fake it
is they're not worried about you as much
as you think mm-hmm
it's [ __ ] ego it's nice one stick
Laura that's why my life is so fun like
like I feel like I'm I equally believe
that I'm gonna change in the world and
be one of the most recognized humans on
earth right correct
and I equally believe I mean zero but
you need to build that relationship with
zero I don't want to do I don't wanna
quit
myself I'm a piece of [ __ ] cuz I am NOT
a piece of [ __ ] but then again I know
stick with me you're not and you're not
you need to stop letting other people's
judgment hold value because they have
other [ __ ] going on it's not about me
correct they're not worried that you
drank and you [ __ ] up as a mother
they're [ __ ] worried about their [ __ ]
do you understand
the best news is the man's ten your
[ __ ] your whole life to be son you
can hold on you have your whole life
spike I see these videos of him I I
replay these videos of him in my
facebook and when he was four and five
he's so amazing
yes the same yesterday I know today
because you need to focus on me for a
second you need to focus on his 12th and
13th and 14th and 15th birthday there's
no there's no [ __ ] time machine Laura
you're not going back to when he's five
you have to you have to at all costs
understand that the only way for you to
win and fix it is to dominate this the
[ __ ] good news you're not even in the
second quarter so let's use football
terms because I love it great you're
down 21 nothing at the end of the first
quarter the Jets were down 32 seven in
the fourth quarter against the Dolphins
and won that game the mundane a miracle
you unlimited time to make it awesome
I'm being dead serious with you it's
gonna be awesome it's gonna be
phenomenal phenomenal so they know it's
because but you have to focus on today
and tomorrow zero about yesterday you
know how proud he's gonna be AB you that
you went on offense from ten on when he
knows the story that you struggled zero
to ten
no but I'm talking when he's 31 when
he's sitting there with mommy was
confused then nanometre because she
knows better that's right and a31
when he's sitting with his buddies he's
gonna say I admire my mom because she
was in a [ __ ] up place for the first
ten years of my life eight years
whatever I don't know the details
and what she's done over the last 23
years has been unbelievable and she he's
gonna then tell one of his friends that
you can do that too you can't spend a
[ __ ] second on yesterday I don't
understand how this whole world thinks
there's a [ __ ] time machine how was
it so hard I get bombarded with you did
this you did that I just want to block
them out [ __ ] [ __ ] themselves who
give me one person real talk give me one
person hey who's that letters your mom
yeah so you gotta say listen I know I
did that now thank you
let's spend five minutes on what you did
wrong no I don't do that I don't throw
things I don't I'm not you're not you're
not following me it's like the zit story
let me take a step back the first time
you say yes mom you're a hundred percent
right and I can't wait to go on offense
in the future that's cool mom now real
quick mom just for fun why don't we
spend five minutes on what you did wrong
then their own I keep getting Lombardy
with it I can't let it go I kick it's
not suffocating listen to me it's not
you have two options you have the
ability to calmly articulate a counter
move to that chess move that then
subsidizes and kind of stops them going
on the offense because they don't want
to look at themselves people cast
judgment because they don't want to
judge themselves people great at judging
everybody else but themselves
no I'm member I'm the best judge myself
I judge myself what I judge others
listen to me you need to come sick or or
or you're not sick you're human we all
have strengths and shortcomings you've
so much you can do
do you understand you you're in control
you either are you take accountability
you take accountability and then you ask
them to talk about their shortcomings
nobody likes that like everybody who
like in my employees my family my
friends they they hate rolling with me
because when they come at it I'm like
you're right I did that wrong by the way
that thing like you can do that or on
some real [ __ ] you can limit your
interaction with them just sort of walk
away it's not walk away
it lets me see everybody makes
everything so absolute that's it I'm
never talking to my mom no that's very
different you know then seeing them one
you know talking texting them once a
week and seeing them once every two
weeks until it gets better or once every
two months until it gets better people
go to the extreme on family judgement
it's like all or nothing no limiting and
and strategizing around that time is
important I need to go to the next floor
Laura I really wish you a lot of success
please rewatch this please like you know
right now we're in it we're in it but I
think this is something good to rewatch
like once a while but listen to me you
really can figure this out I really
believe that and you're you know you're
in the muck but I know you can you're
blessed but you listen to me lord thank
you but listen to me please tomorrow and
today there's no [ __ ] time machines
you what you know rule you can do this
Laura thank you focus on the offense of
the good there's so much good what a
blessing
what a [ __ ] blessing life life might
have given you a lot of challenges it
also gave you an ex-husband that put
your son in a position that gives you
such a bright future you you have to
understand that you've got shitty things
you got certain DNA traits that let the
things you got parenting situations
other things I get it I get it but you
can't like you get to choose what you
decide to look at you do now your mom
not me a nut time machine you so choose
to look at the good [ __ ] I'm good
and I know the hard wire
makes you go back to the badge I get it
I really genuinely get it but you can be
disciplined it's like working out you
can chop away please do me a favor
please just rewatch this once a week
okay I promise take care Thanks thank
you thank you you're welcome so much
let's keep it going
hi my name is Mark and I am 9 years old
I live in Apex North Carolina and I have
a food blog and am on social media and
Facebook
no not social media it's a grandma
Facebook
awesome should I do anything else to
increase my likes and followers the
first thing you should do Harrison is
never ever value likes and followers can
we stick on this subject yes my concern
I know you're a very young man but what
I don't want you to do is have your
self-esteem and your feelings wrapped up
in likes and followers I don't want you
to feel validated like and I know
everybody does Harrison even eighty
eight year olds even great-grand posits
- it's okay but it's important for you
to not overly value likes and followers
the key for you is to make videos that
make you happy okay do you understand
because you know that you and your
friends they talk about how many tick
tock followers or subscribers and
everybody gets caught up in the game and
what ends up happening my man is
eventually then when it doesn't go as
well you get sad
it's like popularity I don't want you
know how popularity in school is already
starting to happen like who's right and
then sometimes if you don't feel popular
you get unhappy I'm worried that that's
what would happen if you care about how
many likes and subscribers you have oh
your old uncle Gary here he didn't have
a lot of subscribers and likes the first
five to seven years of what he did seven
years ago you were two years old so why
he'd be real patient and just make what
you want to make and then maybe when
you're 20 you'll be happy where it's at
does that make sense
yeah you need
make epic food content because you love
it right mm-hmm
not don't even look at the likes and
followers until you're 18 then you call
me and then I'll help you get a whole
bunch more if you want got you all right
take care you do go back I thought you
loved this show
big announcements coming on the internet
you can see it everywhere by this
afternoon you'll know your man was a
part of that situation so I can't wait
for you to see that wine Tech's got a
monster today Dustin let's throw that up
I've got a little bit of a monster on
wine text today I should have to write
that up in a little bit so if you're not
signed up yes sir I think you're ending
at 10 today I am I think so
I am okay I just wanted to remind you
just in case I appreciate it no I know
it was nice yeah not a lot of them but
pretty deep yeah just say hello to some
peeps oh man Vicky how are you low heat
just a soda what's good brother and
stick
Dustin put back my text I need some sign
ups on my dad
Tasha thank you so much you guys think
about today's episode pretty tense huh
allegro I love you back Carla do you pay
the ball people it's good
ginger I have to end I'm sorry Sarah B
what's good what is real David what's up
I really appreciate you guys this was an
emotional one it was a deep one deep sea
yeah
love you see you tomorrow morning 9:00
a.m. Eastern set your alarms get your
friends on and please pay very close
attention to Instagram this afternoon
it's going to get real interesting real
fast
see ya
so team Gary has made a lot of content
over the years but what's your favorite
piece of content
it was makes a great question my
favorite content by far is I'm
considering doing a vaynermedia
operation stay-at-home day once a week
forever because I'm I'm pretty sold that
I've gotten more done per day and
sometimes at a month